From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Okay, this is Emily Crosby with Mrs. Frankie Adams Johnson, December 6, 2015 in Jackson, Mississippi.
We're here with the Civil Rights History Project, sponsored by the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
And John Bishop is also here doing a recording. Thank you very much for doing the interview with us.
Can you tell me when and where you were born and about your family?
Okay, I was born in the little town called Pocahontas, Mississippi. It's about 15 minutes north of here.
And then I was born there into a family of sharecroppers. And I was suddenly up there and the program had a specific group up there until I was about 12 years old and my books moved to Jackson, Mississippi.
What more precipitated there moved to Jackson?
Just a hot life of sharecroppers, my parents. They were separated but I actually was to do it.
I'm the daughter of four girls, born into a first marriage of merchant and Adams.
My mother was a merchant in my daddy at Easton Adams. And so my mother pretty much doing my upbringing in Pocahontas, Mississippi, I was raised by my mom and the village, really, my mom, my grandparents, my great grandparents.
So just the rigor of sharecroppers and being a Singaporean, so my mother got pretty much the desire to share Kroppin life and so she was a domestic worker.
And so she grabbed our children and moved us to Jackson, Mississippi.
And what did she do in Jackson?
She actually started out as a domestic worker here in Jackson, Missouri, Marrett and her first half. She was a homeowner, became a homeowner here.
She did like that. That was liberating for her. It was liberating for Herbicus and actually landed in her position of being one of the terms of local business women.
So she ran a mom and a popsicle, a mom and a popsicle and turned it into a boom and be in this year in Jackson.
What was it like for you? What old were you when you moved to Jackson?
My take was about 12 out between 15. I went back and went back and went back to that period.
You were around very early teen years.
What was it like for you to move to Jackson?
It was really interesting. It was depressing because it seemed to well, and I grew up and I actually liked the freedom of the rule of Harvard.
And when we got to Jackson, because my mother was not, did not own property, so we had to move into a very cramped up into a smaller apartment.
It was kind of depressing. It took some of you to get used to the freedom of being able to just roam and run around in the woods and all that stuff.
I'm a nature girl. I love country living. I still do.
I can appreciate that. What were your schools like?
I have a bunch of different parts of poker. I did not know until I got to be 6th grade.
I went to church schools and I lived in Pocahontas, Mississippi. I went to church schools from the time I entered school until I was 5th grade.
I finished 5th grade at church schools and then we rebused to a district school in Clinton, Mississippi.
So I took the bus to the Clinton. It was really interesting growing up in Pocahontas, Mississippi.
I know you hear a lot about how bad and how terrible and how things were.
I actually enjoyed my school in Pocahontas, Mississippi. I grew up in a Pocahontas, Mississippi looks like a village.
I grew up for me. It was quite different from that school. It relates to school.
Once we started to bus and having to take the bus to school, there were times when I really did not go to school because we had to do a holiday season or do a plant and season.
We had to stay out of school and have fun with the crops.
I think that was my first realization of what it meant to be black and poor and what it meant to be a sharecropper.
I was a school and I was a little bit more into school.
I was a little bit more into school and I was a little bit more into school.
When you had to stay home and work in the school, you said that's the first realization?
That was kind of our first realization of what it meant to be black and poor. I grew up black and poor.
I began to wonder about, you know, why I was in going to school before I actually went to a district school where we had to take the bus to school.
We had to walk to one of the church schools that I attended. My mom was constantly moving to because we were a sharecropper.
We had different plantations and I wanted those plantations. We had to walk through to get to the church school that I attended.
We had to walk to town through town. We were basically focused on this very small place.
There's a little strip of H Street where whites live and so we had to pass through to town and the H Street and walked the H Street to get to our church school.
I think those kind of experiences basically grew and up. Really did I get to see, we knew that there was a black world but in terms of really knowing I have an experience of what that world was like.
We were pretty much protected from that world. I think having to walk through town and walk to our house is a realization of difference.
I think that was the first time I had a black world and what it meant to be black and poor began to hit me and house me to wonder a lot because I grew up in a religious environment also.
I wanted to take this course to wonder about what it was like. I had an active imagination and I was wondering about things so that if God was the image of what God must look like and that it was a white God.
If he was a white God and then these people who didn't like black like me, then how could he possibly like me. Those kinds of things growing up that I had in terms of differences and racial issues.
I was in until 1954 when Emmett Tears was murdered. Just from my appearance and the fear that prevailed in our community really made me start wondering.
We just heard talk about what happened but we never really knew that this little boy about our age and gotten killed.
I think that's why I was so very, very afraid and frightened for us. I think that it's just a race and racial consciousness began to form in my head during that time.
The school and it's what you asked about. I think just particularly having to stay out of school. I probably because education in black communities always stressed out here.
My great grandmother taught us before I even went to school last my great grandmother. My blind great grandmother had taught me math for this and I have to count.
So school was always important to me because of what was in courage and stressed as a family and so having to not be able to attend a school doing certain periods that really left a lasting impression on me in terms of why you have to stay out of school.
Did your mother or anyone else actually talk to you about it or were you just sort of over here and there?
Things were talked about things. Things weren't talked about so much in our household. I heard a lot of stuff from sitting around, sitting under the quilting frame actually because I was quite nosy.
So I went here, particularly ladies, would sit around the quilting frame and I don't know if you should because your grandmother used to do so.
The quilting frame, you know what that's like, right?
Sort of like raising.
So it was raised up and I know a group of women would sit around the quilting frame and you could hear all kinds of stories.
So I would hear stories. I heard stories about the people who lived on that white strip, you know, with the white picket, with the houses, the white houses, and the picket fence.
And it was almost a appearance, particularly women worked in those houses and so I hear really crazy well stories about, you know, what that means, some of those people were in about that person.
You know, when I saw that movie they helped, I said, I'm real for me, it was that because I've heard those stories from up here.
And some experience, my mother worked in one of the most domestic and one of those houses, I do recall, I go and to visit with her.
And so we would always have to go to the back door and she would see because food out of the back door, we could go into those houses.
And so, there's also kind of things that you had to make impressions on me, you know, about, and the question of why, you know, yeah, yeah.
What was your school in like when you moved to Jackson?
When I moved to Jackson, the neighborhood that I went in there were two, two, two, three black house schools in Jackson.
The one that I started at the high school, actually started high school in Jackson.
So probably when you asked me about moving from, this was a transition from from junior to high school.
And I actually went to the newest of the three black house schools, which was Sam M. Brinkley High School.
And it was interesting because it was the newest of the black house schools and it kind of had the top of the art equipment.
So we still, I think we're still using books, but there were a lot of things that that school offered, that the other three schools, that are two schools, the older two older schools did not offer.
And that was my high school years, was under richest, was my richest experience because of the activities that the school did offer.
And I think we did not write up until the freedom of this came.
It was not, once we began, once I began school here, then I had a life of missing the freedom of Holker Hines and the Freedom Rides.
And once I began school here, then I began to really get into Lycan Jackson a little bit more.
And then I had a school life that really hit me to really like my experience here in Jackson.
But it was doing that time that, I think probably a year after we moved here, I think it was the Freedom Rides.
I think we would move this year to probably about in Jackson, about 59, sort of freedom of the the Freedom Rides.
And that's when things began to shift for me and things began, I realized things were happening in Jackson.
And one of my classmates, a father was an end-of-lacif human.
And a lot of things was happening here in Jackson.
And again, it was not talked about by Pinger Still, then talked about things to us, but there was...
Did you get any classmates about it?
Well, what happened is that...
I'm starting to think about, are you, so you're about a sophomore in high school when the Freedom Rides comes?
Something like that?
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
And the course, I remember, the course was a government of the religious government.
I began to shift in terms of what we were being taught and new things very unfamiliar to me were commonism.
And I was clueless to what that word meant.
And so, Slingrich, David, we began to...
I was supposed to assume, he must have mandated their instructors to talk about what was going on, but in a negative light to deter us from getting involved and so on.
So I wanted to know what that word meant, you know, like this.
And I was, this we were taught to...
And I was what, the lesson was taught commonism.
And I wanted to know, so I asked my God-brother, whose daddy was very active in the NAACP.
And so he began to tell me about the the Freedom Rides and things that was going on here in Mississippi.
And so I wanted to go more and more and more.
So I started going to...
They would have meetings at his father, the NAACP would have meetings at his father's house.
And so I started going to those meetings with him.
And so I got to meet Megan and this eventually started going to mass meetings.
So this was about 62 when I started. And 63.
Can you just write what it's like for you as a high school student to be sitting in on these meetings of the NAACP?
Can you give us like a picture of that?
Yeah, I would tell you, I would see it, I would tell you the one of the most impressive.
And it was a singing, I think, that really got me in a Miss Vanity Lou Hamer,
was probably with all of you, because I was always...
I was just so anxious because there were always such...
It was always excitement and the sense that that's what I thought,
the sense that there's excitement and people would talk about the things that I was so unfamiliar to me.
But I was really...
But I always try to get a fructose seat so that I could hear more.
Miss Vanity Lou Hamer, I would love to hear her sing.
I would sit there and just sit there and gaze like a starry-eyed kid.
I didn't want to just...
You know, just to just want one, because I didn't know any other woman like that.
I mean, I knew I was raised around women pretty much.
You know, I was raised around my green parents, my grandmother's and my great-grandma.
But this was a different title woman.
And so it was like...
I started to sit there because a starry-eyed kid and I remember thinking,
how I want to be like that woman there.
And it was Miss Vanity Lou Hamer, Miss Annie D. Van,
and Miss Victoria Gray.
And those were three women that just kind of impressed me as a young woman.
It was like, wow.
Did you have the congressman?
I don't know that she was doing that.
That was when it was late on, maybe in the 64s around that.
Yeah, this was before then.
This was, as I said, I started going to Mass meetings in about 62.
And 63 was when I became really...
when I had my first act of courage came in 63.
That the two blue college students, the two blue nand,
they had to try to integrate.
Because now I was meeting these college students.
One lived in our neighborhood, one of the persons who was involved in the...
the Woolworth's City.
And she lived in my neighborhood and she was also one of the youth leaders of the...
at this point I had John Jackson of Youth Council.
And you know, the mega-ebra started up.
And the North Jackson Youth Council.
And Pearlena Lewis was a member of...
well, actually, she was not a member of our church,
but she lived in our neighborhood.
And we occasionally went to the same church.
So she was one of the two blue students who...
sat in at the Woolworth's.
And it was doing that period though.
May 31, 1963 was the first, actually, much that...
well, now I'm gonna...
I spoke to you about the fairground.
And so this is leading up to the fairground.
I knew that Cleveland, my god brother,
who had introduced me to pretty much the moon,
and then went all of this myth...
had a guy named Bob Knight,
and helped it organize the students.
The history were worth...
the May 28, I believe.
This is about three days before we marched.
We were marching in response to the brutal attack on the...
the two blue students.
And Anne Moody and John Salter,
and so that day that they had gotten beat up there.
And so Migger had organized the high school students
to protest.
And so I had a clue of what this was like,
except that I was really excited about it.
And I had no clue.
Even though the students had gotten brutally attacked
during the lunch counter,
I had no clue what might happen to us.
I was just a teenager who's like eager to be a part of something.
And what proceeded when we organized...
and it was very well organized that the three black high schools
that would walk out,
students would walk out of through Jim Hill High School,
and Jim Hill High School in West.
And, frankly, in North Jackson,
I guess you say it's kind of central.
And so we would converge.
We would march downtown,
but we never got any further.
We got about a quarter of a mile from our school.
And what happened to you?
It was something like, I guess not a, you know,
a toilet zone or something like that.
All of a sudden we were just converged,
all by all of these.
The top-santake.
It was just trucks and garbage trucks.
And whatever be hiccups,
it just came in and surrounded back
by all of these police with guns and hafnests.
And it was just...
I can say subtabitly.
You know, the twilight zone was something.
I mean, I don't know that anybody prepped us in the end
of trying to remember where we ever prepped.
I don't know that we ever prepped.
Maybe we were probably young people just not paying attention.
We're going to march.
I knew we was going to march.
But what happened after we were sent
and being taken to the fairground?
And I don't know if anyone told you the story of the fairground,
but the where they housed us and it really felt like,
like, a little on, I did liken it to a concentration camp
and then mega, also likened it to, I was saying,
this reunion and some of this stuff in New York,
it's a likened to a concentration camp.
Once I realized what a concentration camp was, I said,
ah, we were treated like that.
You know, that we were put in though.
We're a really loud livestock, I kept during the fair.
And just concrete floor, no cuts, no anything.
And so that night, when you were talking about,
or if we were talking about this form in this circle,
because it did feel dangerous.
It felt dangerous to be surrounded by so many men.
And so many of this at that time,
we were no blackheads, so you get really red-faced.
White cast, you know, the guns cocked
and that's the way they kind of walked around.
With their guns kind of cow-fed.
I think I saw something like that when I saw the movie,
Sarah Fena.
And, well, they walked around.
And they guided us with guns.
And they set very nasty things.
And tried to, you know, set fear in us.
And we did, well, the guys, you know,
form a circle to protect the girls, you know.
And so that was the basically way we had to protect ourselves.
It was kind of just band together, you know,
and enclose each other in this circle.
What was your god brother's last name?
Donald, Cleveland Donald Jr, Donald.
He's now deceased, but really he was very active.
He was eventually, he became the one of the youth leaders.
Yes, he was the third.
Well, I see there was a change.
James Meredith was the first black man to attend.
Then, Cleve McDowell, Cleve McDowell,
MacDonald, I believe it was.
And, of course, he got expelled because he had been a gun.
They found a gun.
So he was still in prison.
Cleveland was the second, because (James) Meredith did it,
and Cleveland was the second to...
And how about your god brother?
He's my god brother.
He was one of your important connections.
He was the connection.
He was the most important connection to the movement,
because I was clueless because my parents just...
You heard about them, basically I heard stories about how bad things were for black people,
but never did they talk about it either.
They'd encourage me to get involved.
And it's a matter of fact, once I became very involved,
and it was after the march, of course, then it was several other marches.
And so that became for me, particularly the summer of 1963,
became my summer.
My summer job was marching in protest, and pretty much.
I lived to reach day to get up and go to the head down to the (Jackson MS) (Jackson MS) Masonic Temple
to wait for my marching orders, whether we had to march,
whether it was through to pass our flaries.
And so shortly after, you know,
Megagot assassinated, shortly after...
My first march, Megagot assassinated in June,
but my first march wasn't...
So Megagot assassinated, and I'm shortly after that.
And that must, Megagot assassinated these things,
began to really...
Did I begin to feel, you know, seriousness of what it meant to be a civil rights?
Would it be a marcher, you know, to be a freedom fighter,
because freedom fighters was how we saw us.
That's what it really meant to be a freedom fighter.
And that it was dangerous being this,
but even with it being dangerous being this the fever of heaven,
I think I got into the marching book, again the freedom book,
and the word freedom, which always for me,
it seemed that I was born with a sense of freedom.
You know, I've always had this sense that I never want to be confined,
I never want to be beat upon,
and I would run away a lot from two-board grippings when I grew up in Pocahontas,
and so I would go into the woods to a wood.
So that freedom, it just rained,
there's something about that word that just rained,
something special to my soul, you know.
And the interesting thing about it in terms of...
I don't want to build marches.
I got hit across my back,
and that was the one after mega,
when mega, they had Medgar Evers' funeral.
I was in jail, many of us was in jail,
because we had, there was a march stage,
right after mega-sassination,
the next day after mega-sassination,
I believe they then organized this march,
and it was really emotionally charged.
It was a really emotionally charged march,
in a lot of us march that day.
And on that particular day,
that was the day that I did get hit across my back,
because I had to, you know,
got into custom to march and demonstrate,
and so I always carried my writing pad with me,
and something to write on.
So this particular day, we were sitting after they had,
because by this time, we would know that,
if you march, you were going to get arrested.
You know, question about, if you march,
you were going to get arrested.
And so this particular day, we marched,
and I had my writing pad,
and it was sitting in a padded wagon,
but it's very, very hot, very, very hot,
and so I was fanning with my writing pad,
and I dropped it on the ground,
and I felt very naive.
I did ask the one who asked the office,
if he would pass it to me,
and just looked at me, you know,
and so I just jumped down to pick it up,
and as I got back into the padded wagon,
with black crusts in my back,
and then he got to scorn,
because on that day,
I think I realized that it was a question of a highland,
it became a question of whether I really was not valid,
because I wanted to fight back,
and I was going to fight back up,
and I went to fight back at him,
and some of the other marches grabbed me,
and said, no, no, no, he got a gun,
and he's cocked at his gun,
and so they pulled me back up into the padded wagon,
and what really infuriated me more about that than anything else?
I had to fight my grandfather,
we were talking about freedom,
my grandfather was a tyrant,
and he believed in being just some jeep he sometimes,
you know, and so I had to fight him,
and defend myself against him,
and I actually violated the secretude
that you don't talk back to your elders,
and you wouldn't dare dream of hitting them,
but I actually had to fight the only man,
so I had never been hit by a man.
I had never been hit by a man,
and the first man that hit me was a white seven police officer,
and so that thing really was a turning point,
and that hit him,
and I think I'd have to make a assassination,
and it all began to really, the seriousness,
and the violence,
and that really began to affect me,
and I think that's when my anger began to sit in,
to kind of suppress it, you know,
because we can fight back,
and I just stayed angry after I was hit across my back,
I stayed angry, I wanted to fight back,
I wanted some kind of sense of gestures,
and the fact that I had defied my own grandfather,
and here I am now,
I can't defy this man, you know,
and I have to stand,
due to this non-violent privacy, you know, so.
Did people talk a lot about non-violence,
or did you go to any workshop?
I went to workshops, you know, where they trained,
this was a matter of fact,
one of the person's Jesse Harris,
he was recently passed,
and he was basically a trainer.
They were trained us down at the,
we got a lot of training,
some of the, the SNCC people,
after mega, after mega's assassination,
we, the young people here in Jackson particularly,
felt to kind of like a void in our life,
because mega was not there to,
to lead and guide us,
and give us a sense of direction,
and then there was the SNCC people
at the, you know, a COFO (Council of Federated Organizations) office,
but many of, you know,
most of the SNCC activities,
much of the SNCC activities were,
were even in McCone,
a green wood,
and so there was this,
so Jesse Harris,
with that he was somehow,
was put as a,
as a elite person for the young people here in Jackson,
Jesse Harris,
then, and so,
so we just kind of started,
many, many of the young people that,
that was marching,
and I'm proud to mega,
I'm doing, doing, doing the time that mega lived.
Now, let's just kind of, kind of,
at the law,
so what did we go,
and what did we do,
and who do we really care about us, really,
because mega was that kind of a person for me.
He was, kind of like a 11-5,
that's just, I didn't grew up with him with the father,
you know, around me,
so that became like my,
my, my idea of what it would be like to have,
what it was like to have a father,
you know, seriously,
so he was, because he had that kind of caring about,
he, before we went out of the street to march,
mega would always,
prepress, and mega would always,
was always concerned particularly,
once we got arrested,
he was very mass-media,
he would always plead with,
with the, the, the older people,
you know, you got to get those young people out of jail,
you know, with the danger of that there,
and we can't let them stay there,
and he was that kind of a caring,
older person,
so many of the young people,
just kind of faded out,
you know, many of the young people that,
that, that, that,
was, was, was going on,
regularly on March,
just kind of faded out,
that Cleveland,
I had no fear of it,
it was, that,
we lived through,
we stayed through this summer,
and the summer of 64 came,
and I went to Tougaloo College.
You know, there's a couple other questions,
before we go on to that.
I've heard about that,
the March on the day of,
the Meagraver's funeral,
and I think that must have been,
you know, when you're arrested,
and people have described this sort of fight,
or conflict between the March and the police.
Yes.
Are you there in the middle of the...
Yes, yes, yes, yes,
and I saw, I think it was probably,
on the first hand,
they actually saw the dogs, you know,
into what a hose,
and all those seams that you see in the eyes of the brave,
when I see it,
and I think they focus a lot,
in the eyes of a proud,
on what happened in Alabama,
or, you know, with the little,
little, little, little, little, little,
but those kind of things
was actually happening right, right?
I think we, if I remember that March,
we started at there,
after the Sunday,
after the point of March,
and so we came from there to downtown,
and I remember almost vividly,
because it seems that there was,
in that route,
it seems that there was also that,
the weight-masonic tip of a somewhere long,
long, long, long bear,
and it was very, very, very furious,
that, you know,
that the dogs in there,
and I don't know,
because one time,
one of those marches,
I remember Martin getting the,
and I don't know if there was a marriage march,
but I do remember,
I remember Martin getting beat,
and one of those marches, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
And, how did your mother and your other family members react to you?
Oh, my mother.
She, well, she tried to,
when my mother would go off to work, you know,
it just kind of sleek out of the house,
because she would tell me, you know,
I want you going back down there in that mess, you know,
and she'd call that mess, you know,
so I don't want you going back,
and you need to stay out of that,
and we wanted she to hear it,
because,
how the woman that she worked for,
a threatened,
my brother,
was my,
it was my brother and I,
out of my family,
my brother and I,
was the wooden marches up from our family,
and so the woman that my mom worked for,
actually did after she came to,
because she came to pick him up from the fear ground,
and so, you know,
women's told him that she would personally beat him,
if he got back into one of the marches, you know.
So she was willing to bail him out,
but then she's...
Well, they were just swip here at the fairground.
And it was just release here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And so,
did your mother's employer,
they came to the fairground?
Yes, yes, the mother's employee brought my mother to get him,
and so she threatened him,
that she would beat him personally,
beat him, he outed, of course, he helped me,
because he thought that my mom should have stood up, you know,
and it's so of course being young,
we didn't realize, you know,
the fear,
and the rift of course,
you know, that was...
that our parents were really, really, yes, you know.
And so,
so he stayed pretty angry.
And I got there too,
because it was like,
how can she let that wait woman talk to my brother like that, you know.
And she,
I've had a long time, my mom,
she wasn't...
wasn't what she could do,
because I would...
whether she could beat me,
if she never did,
she just threatened me, you know,
if you get back in that way again.
But she was more upset
because she blamed me
for that first time we march,
they did not discriminate,
you know,
just marches and the spectators.
So they just rounded all the children up.
So when my mom came home,
and that would actually...
actually, I didn't watch that thing when they get...
she tells the story of that,
before she died,
she tells the story about how the mates,
all the mates,
you know, they,
you know, when the way folks went around,
they were trying to SNCC a call to fan.
I just just jumped out there,
and you know,
how they was fear for you,
you know, they were gonna lose their jobs.
And so that first night,
my mom,
I was...
what my brother,
it was all four of us still.
So my brother and my two younger siblings had gotten just pooled in.
And my brother and I,
actually,
we were a part of the organ-as much,
but a lot of the young kids that was on the set,
and I'm watching because my...
my younger brother and my younger sister were still in junior high school,
and, well,
the break-up was junior high.
So we were high school,
and the youngest was still in junior high.
So of course,
junior high school kids were not a part of the march,
but many of them did get pooled in.
And so they basically, first night, they let the...
they identified you, you don't stay here because you were organ-as-and-you,
they kind of identified the people that they thought were the leaders,
and they kept us there, you know.
Was that after the 209?
Yeah, that was after the 209.
Did you pass that page?
They did. They surely did.
It's a matter of fact.
It was terrible.
It was the dogs.
It was the water.
I don't know if the tear gas...
I remember tear gas more on Lynch Street, you know,
when we were the tear gas.
But I don't know if it was tear gas,
but I do remember the water and the dogs.
I remember that really clearly.
I remember the dogs were airing up though, you know,
it was really clearly, you know.
Did you know any of the older, like the college-age students,
like Colia Liddell and Harry?
Yes, yes, yes.
Yes, during...
I met all of those people when I went to Tougaloo.
I went to Tougaloo, and that's where we had it.
In 1964, I went to Tougaloo on a music scholarship.
I went to Tougaloo College.
And so, because I was so...
I had spent the summer of 63 just being in the movement.
And I went there, and that was the summer of 1964,
when I went there.
It was Freedom Summer.
And I remember going there, and I went there as a pre-freshman.
And because I was so in-drenched with the movement,
of course, was Freedom Summer, and all the people there
were there on campus.
And so, that's how I got involved with...
There's a SNCC worker, because I was already involved,
and you know, the movement had to be involved in the movement.
But I met all the SNCC people when I went to Tougaloo College,
so it was your syndrome, or, you know, all of them.
What was it like to get out of Tougaloo?
You know, you've been in the movement,
and meet all these older people, and these full-time activists?
It was very, very challenging in this sense,
that the older, lot of the older people didn't treat us
with the same kind of respect.
You know, we couldn't...
We couldn't travel, you know, ever now.
I think when Stokely Carmichael came, and Stokely Carmichael took us on a history
and I went to Greenwood to do various photos,
and the registration work, when Stokely Carmichael came there.
But being at Tougaloo, one of the things that connected us,
and it was about six young women, all together,
six of us, who had...
Well, one of the persons that was my friend became...
my friend in a prefreshing program,
her mother, Annie Devine, daughter, and I was in school.
So we were in the prefreshing program together,
so that kind of...
because she was the daughter of Annie Devine,
so that gave us some sense of importance, you know,
as it relates to being a part of the movement.
But we went, necessarily,
well, first of all,
they knew the danger of it, you know,
so we were trying to just take people...
young kids off, you know, somewhere,
and exposed them to the danger, you know,
of movement life.
But I, one of the editors,
we had tutors from Brown University,
and that kind of helped us to get more involved,
you know, having those tutors from Brown
because they were all so proud of, you know,
the activities that was going on there on campus.
But one of the biggest challenges that I had
is that I was so involved in it.
I mean, my whole, whole, whole being at two college
was supposedly of a staff for the prefreshing program.
That's what got me there.
But because I had been so active in movement,
that had just become a part of my life,
and so I would spend much of my time, you know,
with being, just being a part of the freedom,
just being a part of the SNCC workers,
and so I actually got kicked out of the program
because the woman who hated up the prefreshing program
was very, very conservative,
and she told me I could not come back to the program,
and I think I've started doing stuff.
My mother has always had an open door policy.
She, we could always bring people home.
So at this time, now I begin to bring white people
to my house, and so this one, my mom was like,
oh, no, no, no, no, no, you know,
she called me and said,
because I mean, I was just used to always,
you know, as we were growing up, my mother,
I always had an open door policy.
We could always bring children to our house,
and she was always feeding people.
And so I just felt, well,
I'm going to take my newfound friends to the house.
And so I took the day, I took my newfound,
white friends to the house,
and my mom was like,
it told me straight up, she called me a sad,
and she says, they're not going to have it,
and I'm not going to have it, you know.
You know, you are really putting us in danger here,
you know, so she was like,
that is dangerous being this you're doing.
You cannot bring those people back here to this house.
I know you do.
I felt just confused.
I really did.
I think it's still right now.
I still do not see if it's getting out of my throat.
But I felt, oh, wow,
that segregation had,
and once I got to Tougaloo
because you know, the soul of such a,
it was nice to mix you up.
It was my first time, one,
it was my first time ever being around.
Wait people in terms of really a close-up intimacy,
I don't know, I love them.
And that, you know,
the wait students that were there at Tougaloo,
I did not treat me in different,
and I guess because I did not personally know
what it's said for him in the time that I was hit
across my back, I knew what it was like to be hit, you know,
by someone that was so feel with hate.
But I did not judge.
I thought, you know, well,
in dead, all white folks are not bad, you know.
They hear some good wait people, you know, and then so,
and I didn't understand my mom was like,
what's wrong with you acting like these people, you know.
And so, you know, it wasn't until like,
you know, I got old and started,
now I can analyze things,
and understood why my parents,
my mom act a certain way, you know,
in terms of that she was, it was fear, you know,
that if you bring,
you could call, you could get killed,
I don't know if they get killed,
you could call, you're just whole family together, you know.
So I think I did not know,
I just wanted my mom to,
I wanted my mom to be a freedom fighter,
I wanted my mom to embrace the movement, yeah, yeah.
Can you tell us what Annie Devine's like?
You know, she is one of those Mississippi movement heroes,
but I don't think very many people around the country.
Annie Devine was very quiet,
but Annie Devine, the three of them,
and I want to talk about it when I talk about Annie Devine,
Annie Devine, and they was just fearless of women,
but she was the quieter one out of all the three
of Miss Victoria and Miss Andy Devano,
and Miss David Lou Hamer,
and Annie Devine was the quieter one of them.
She was just very, I just remember her being very, very quiet,
you know, very quiet,
and I think probably she, I try to get her daughter to,
to Barbara, to talk about her mom,
but more and to maybe write about her mom, yeah, yeah.
That would be wonderful.
Yeah, maybe because out of the three of them,
she, she does,
and because she, I guess she was, the quieter one, you know.
Yeah, she doesn't, I don't think she does well on the own.
No, she's not, but it's so,
when, as I say, I know from those three,
those three women, they were always together.
They were always going to get a wonderful organ,
as you see now.
So you got kicked out of the pre-fresh from the program,
and you still enrol into Lou and that.
Yeah, they allowed me to come back in the fall.
You know, I got kicked out of the program,
but I was able to come back to the fall,
and I remember,
and it was really interesting.
I can't have got kicked out of it.
And Tougaloo is known as the hotbed of the Civil Rights Movement,
but then everybody at Tougaloo was not necessarily progressive,
because I remember when the director,
Mrs. Towns, Dr. Towns,
and so really interested because now,
they have students who have mixed shoes
or opinions about her,
but she, I think she was one of those eight people
that she just wanted to tell us the ten.
You know, she, well, behaves to you,
and you're here for this and you,
and all of that stuff there is not why you're here.
And she had a lure to that when she kicked me out of the program.
She did save because you know,
you've been into much time involved with those people, you know?
Yeah.
So, you know, so there,
all of the people at Tougaloo,
you know, people who say,
well, Tougaloo is hotbed of the Civil Rights Movement,
but everyone at Tougaloo did not necessarily,
even my quiet director,
I probably would,
now that I've met you,
I know all of those,
the women,
I wanted to be regular,
like them, you know?
And so when I went back,
you know,
doing, doing, doing the false semester,
so I wanted to take on this character
what it meant to be a Civil Rights Office,
a SNCC work, you know?
The ladies and girls was wearing overalls,
and they were not in their hair up,
you know, napping up the hair.
And so, I was on a music scholarship,
and so my quiet director,
who was also very rare,
he was a great, wonderful quiet director,
one of the greatest here.
But now, was not
particularly interested in movement activities, you know?
So, when I,
whenever we had to perform,
he would pull me aside,
saying, now, young lady,
you're going to have to straighten that hair.
You know, I could never wear my hand at your home,
when we were performing, you know?
So, you had that kind of mixture there, too,
you had the Berenc ski tags
who embrace social change
and encouraged us in sociology classes, you know?
And talked about social issues, you know?
And so, you had the Borinskis,
but then you had the towns,
you had to pop a little place,
and you also had,
I remember one time,
we actually protested on the president's line, you know?
Because, the president,
Dr. George A. Owens, which was very,
he was very conservative,
but interesting enough,
he did keep up with all that went on,
and it's related to movement.
I had an opportunity,
and I moved back here,
to work in,
civil-disobedience archive,
a work at the archive,
and I had an opportunity to work on his papers,
and I actually found out,
he had such a rich collection
of the civil rights of,
the only activities that was going on,
and I actually read,
and his spouse,
organized in his papers,
I actually got to read a lot of,
the details of things that I had missed
from just being out there,
being an activist,
and not knowing all the details of,
everything that was going on.
I don't think that would be very interesting.
But, to be able to read those things.
No, it was,
I would sit there just,
just when we were processing his paper,
I would just sit there,
and I would just really conserve it to President,
kept these really rich files
on all of the super-high-sacped images.
So you said that you had met,
like a Joyce Ladner,
and some of the other women in SNCC,
and you wanted to look like them?
Yeah, I wanted to look like them.
I didn't want to.
So the first thing I'd be able to do was to,
I think I never,
never got me in O'Boss,
but I actually,
yeah,
I said, well, at least I could not make it there,
yeah, they were like my role models.
I looked up to them because they could get to do things,
and when they went to O'Boss,
and that sounds really, really sat down for me,
because all of those big girls
that was going places,
they could go to Atlanta,
they could go to Atlantic City,
and the only thing that my mom did allow me to do,
I did go to my show in Washington.
I thought she allowed me to go to the washroom,
but I actually did go to my show.
That was an interesting experience.
It was really interesting when we left out of Jackson
to go to Washington.
I remember my first stop within Meridian,
and so we had our first stop in Meridian.
And when we'd gone out of Jackson,
of course, you know, we were very excited,
and so, of course, we went to the rest stop,
and we took color folks like that,
and we didn't even think of going to the wave folks there.
But...
I don't know.
Was it a bus?
We were on a bus.
About six buses left out of Jackson.
And so they had the bus of ministers.
I remember that most of the ministers were on a bus,
and they were a bus that just carried us young people,
and we had chafferons, of course.
But I do recall that,
so when we came back,
once we got to Washington,
and of course, that was just so...
It was just so much excitement.
It was just so much going on,
and so many people that as a young person,
you just felt just like,
I'm just happy to be a part of it, you know?
And I remember that most of it was like one big picnic for me.
You know, I kind of kind of sat,
and I remember sitting around the monument,
and putting my feet in the water,
and just hanging out of me,
and all the speeches.
But it was so exciting.
It did feel like for a young person like me,
that we had...
Because I was at my first...
No, my first...
There was my first trip about a Mississippi,
but it was the first trip that ever met anything,
you know, it was so, so powerful,
you know, just to be in this sea of people,
just to be a part of this sea of people.
And so I did feel a sense of that,
that in my young man,
that we had done something in Washington,
that we, that just by the time we went there,
I met that things had changed,
that we had changed Mississippi somehow,
so when we came back,
and we were so fired up from all of that energy,
I mean, that same stuff in Meridian again.
And this time,
we did not go on the color folks at.
We just said that it's now...
It's time.
We're going to integrate, you know,
so we just naturally went to the White Sad,
to the restroom,
and that there is a...
And that people, I believe,
that bus stop then had a lunch counter there,
so we came, so I remember coming out of the restroom,
and we came out of the restroom,
a fight had broken out,
so it was a group of young white thugs,
and they were on motorcyclists,
so they'd come in,
and they began to attack the men.
And so, when that happened,
we were like, we don't fight back,
we just came from watching on Washington,
and we were not going to take no more of this here.
So the menace...
So what's the reason we came out of the restroom
because the fate...
Out of the restroom,
out to the outside now,
so that's when we realized the whole town
of whites had come out.
It was a mob,
they had come out,
and they actually were not in clans with the uniform,
but they...
It was a plan,
so they were...
I remember they were kind of dressed in black and white,
they were not in clans uniform,
and so what happened
that the gang of thugs had initiated the attack,
but then the mob began to throw things at us,
and it was just crazy,
so the menace of the gang between us,
because we were in a fight,
we were like, we're not going to take...
At that point,
it was like enough of an unbalanced,
we were going to fight back, you know?
And so we were actually prepared to fight back.
Well, as they prepared,
we were attempting to fight back,
and the ministers got between us and the mob
and pleaded with us to please get back on the bus fleet,
so eventually they got us quite down,
and we did get back on the bus,
but we were told by, I guess, the chef or whoever,
that we were the men here,
and so we wanted to see the judge,
and so they told us to come back.
Sometimes I was speaking,
I'm trying to remember the days
that must have been the one we got back,
it must have been a week in,
and so we went back to Father and a week for here,
and we were told that the judge was going to fish in,
so we don't know if it would happen,
or if nothing ever became of it,
but before I left Mississippi,
I mean, Megah had gotten assassinated,
it's just in terms of right up front
and close to things that are definitely in the violence
that affected my life,
and there was a young man here
that got shot down and witnessed that,
and down the Lynch Street,
and so I think after that,
and my mom actually began to get concerned,
because I really was,
I was angry a lot,
and so my brother and I,
in a group of kids,
we were sometimes just,
particularly after the march in Washington,
and we came back,
because that just steered up a different kind of anger,
you know, that,
and that yes, this will not start.
We can continue to get beat up,
and we can't fight back,
and so that's what we were told,
and also once there,
I think we'll even be 67,
when this Benjamin Brown guy shot down here on the Lynch Street,
and I don't know what that approach was
with the nature of that protest,
but the details of it,
but I do remember a march in the Lynch Street,
and I do remember that,
but this time the National Guard
had been brought in
for this demonstration for it,
and I think there was something to go on
over at Jackson State,
when Phillip Lafayette Gibbs and James Earl Green had taken the bus,
and we had two blue stoos that had left,
and they had to go and just put the stoos up
and that happened,
which was at Jackson State.
It wasn't when those groups,
not when those two guys,
you know, the green and,
and that wasn't that,
the something that has happened at Jackson State,
and because Jackson State seems
always been for being too.
But was there one somebody
that drove through the light
when the lights were dry through the campus?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
and Benjamin Brown,
the Shambla,
yeah, they had chosen,
because I don't know the National Guard
had come out on this particular march here,
and this particular protest,
it was a protest,
right there on the street,
and so in our training,
someone had told us
that the National Guard
would not shoot
unless fired upon.
So a lot of us had,
because of all the things that we were experiencing
in terms of the brutality,
you know, this was after (James) Meredith,
you know,
so we had began to do things
that really could have gotten this key of magnitude,
but then we were just young,
you know, and angry.
And so I think we were throwing something at them,
and they turned around and said,
buh-bh-bh-bh-bh-bh-bh-bh-bh-bh-bh-bh-bh-bh-bh-bh-bh-bh-bh-bh-bh-bh-bh.
And so we were running into Alice,
and we had a week of run,
at the end of that evening,
Benjamin Brown had been, been, been, been,
and she killed by the National Guard.
Did you know him?
Just from one of the many kids
that I knew from,
not like he wasn't from my neighborhood,
he was from out there in West Jackson around,
around the college.
She lived around there.
But I saw a lot of the kids,
you know, I did not necessarily know from other schools,
you know, when we met up at the (Jackson MS) (Jackson MS) Masonic Temple,
we pretty much knew each other from there,
but not personally, you know.
Yeah.
So it was kind of after that,
that my mom was just,
she really became very concerned.
And so,
she wanted me to lead Mississippi,
and so I left,
she called my older sister,
came for the summer.
And so she said that she would,
yeah, I could go back to New York,
and so once I got to New York,
about 67?
Yes, that's 67.
So once I got to New York,
I didn't know anything else that I did in the movement,
so I was disconnected because
I went to live with my sister,
and my sister lived in the suburbs in New York,
and so I started longing
for it, for this connection of movement,
you know, I started longing for it,
for that connection,
and so in New York,
what seemed to been going on,
there was kind of like a culture,
you know, we were more into,
to get into African culture,
you know, that stuff.
So I started going to,
to meetings from white planes,
New York, to Intementan hadn't,
with the culture of nationalist group of women.
Amiri Baraka, you might have heard the name,
Amiri Baraka's wife,
and some of the other,
so this is a world culture,
yeah, so I'm meeting with those.
And I was, so I used to be an actor,
being a grassroots organist,
and doing, getting up,
doing things,
and mostly this was an intellectual group of women,
and he basically did a lot of,
kind of semantics,
and so not the kind of movement
that I was a little accustomed to,
and so I haven't gone to one of those meetings,
I actually met a group of people
on the streets of Harlem,
125th Street,
and 7th Avenue,
with black leather,
and I liked the language they were talking,
I liked the sense I liked them,
that they were out on the street,
they were with the people,
and I got accustomed to,
they were in Mississippi,
so I was impressed,
and I inquired about who they were,
and so I don't know that I had,
I'm trying to remember,
I don't know if I had,
I had a head of black paint,
so this was probably at 68,
yeah, this was like maybe,
it's spring of 68, right?
Spring of 68,
and so I wanted to be a part of that group of people,
I mean, it seemed to be the thing
that I was looking for to fulfill the void
of not having movement activity in my life,
and so I,
they didn't have a branch of a black paint party
in white planes in New York,
and so that time to travel there,
and so still young,
and I didn't know much about getting around,
so I could raise it,
so to ask me if I wanted to start a branch
of a black paint party in white planes in New York,
so then my life drastically begins
to change, there's brought someone in from
I think California,
and they helped my sister and I
to set up a branch of a black paint party in New York,
and so at this time,
I was...
I'm sister's own boy.
She was own boy!
She was really on board,
at this time I was working at a,
well, I was at a first-foot to New York,
I started teaching at a home,
a broker, a broker at a home school for children,
and so shortly after that,
I started teaching at a daycare center,
and so I really...
just thought, I don't know,
I think I thought that everyone was
becoming conscious of this movement stuff,
and it was just my world,
and so I started taking my black paint
of papers to work with me,
of course, that job in last.
And everybody was on board with that.
Everyone was on board with that.
You know, so I...
Because, so I started...
I started a liberation school
with the young kids that I was working with at the daycare center.
At the same time,
a lot of us going on in white planes,
and once I began to become
politically conscious there in New York,
and look at the issues that it was different
that we were...
we were fading, you know,
a lot of segregation,
and that kind of stuff here.
But what was happening there in New York
is that that black people were living very, very poorly,
and then there was a urban...
I remember they called it Urban Renewal,
then at that time,
that's pretty much what they call the re-ginification now,
but what it was,
Urban Renewal,
because then black people,
people being moved from their homes,
and then moved into tenement buildings,
and my sister's home,
the home that we lived in,
was one of those houses,
and so that became an issue there in white planes,
and so I got very involved in that issue,
and the building that they had put us in,
after they took over, you know,
our neighborhood,
and it's a matter of fact,
it's a shopping center there,
where we used to live now,
they built a shopping center there in white plane.
And so,
the high-rise building that they put us in,
they had a big hear-centered there,
so I began to set up my own...
No, there became a fight between...
there was a conflict in the interest,
because I went to start a big hear-centered in the building
that we lived in,
and the agency that I worked with wanted those buildings,
so that became a conflict,
and then, so I got very involved in that fight
and the guests there were removed,
they were in white planes,
and eventually, we could cut through some of the chase of my work
with a black pen to say,
it was moved from...
because of the organizing that I was doing there in white planes,
the central committee moved me,
we wanted to place me in...
where...
where it was...
most needed,
what they considered was crucial, you know,
to...
they moved me from white planes,
and placed me in browns via New York,
and then it was probably browns meals,
one of the biggest ghettos in South Bronx,
and then in the city,
and so I was placed there,
and to...
I was the officer of the day there,
and Brooklyn,
yeah.
Can you explain what that means?
What does that...
You said in a piece of office?
The day means that you're a pretty much in charge
of all the activities that go signed, you know,
and oversee,
and the office and the daily activities.
So, I know people have very strong opinions
and so different directions about what it was like to be a woman in the panthers.
What was your experience?
Well, I want to say that I...
actually, what it was like there was...
yeah, the Vector Pignus Dubere,
I think in New York,
being a panther woman in New York,
was a bit more liver-rated
and that we truly did,
that men there seemed to have a bit more respect for women leadership,
and so then the California guys used to come through.
They thought that it was just okay
that when they came through that it was okay to have socialistic sex,
they called it, you know,
and so that was a California attitude, you know,
that yeah,
and we're seeing that they come with socialistic sex,
and we went to down with that.
But all that,
that in terms of decision-making,
that women did get to participate in it,
in decision-making,
and women could hold,
you know, office, such as the officer of the day,
you know, whole key positions.
Now, don't get me wrong with that,
that people think that that,
I guess it was just all the way equality.
You know, there was a lot of show-inism, you know,
we did it, it was,
if you were a female and had a man
to protect you, you know,
because there was this just attitude
that we're socialists,
and we don't get caught up on,
you know,
the traditional way of relationships,
and so,
if it was definitely challenging, you know,
to be a female when it came to sex, you know,
I went, it came to families,
so that was one of the things,
and when I look back and retrospect,
I do think that we spent a lot of time
serving the people,
and kind of forgot, you know,
kind of got lost along the way
that our families were also part of the people,
and so, so, so, so families did,
we began, you know,
I eventually got married to a parent,
and so as a result of (James) Meredith to a parent of man,
many of us,
have seen a parent,
because many of the parents have been in the infancy jail,
and I also had my own challenges in terms of that life,
as you know,
that we did experience a lot of confrontations
with law enforcement,
and so, so, so,
as a result of that,
many of us,
I'm probably one of the few women who actually survived
a very terrible experience,
you know, being a parent to a woman,
and that I actually did live underground for about four years,
and I gave birth to my youngest daughter, you know,
when I was under a ride.
So, I think when looking back at the retrospect of the panties,
it's definitely a very controversial one,
it's very controversial,
but it's also a,
you can't just put panties in a bag and say,
well, it was bad,
it was good,
it had, it's, it's,
so, when I tried to look at that experience,
I tried to look at what work and what did not work.
I think as families,
it did not work well in terms of raising a family.
I think it worked well in terms of challenging the system
and looking at
much broader than just civil rights,
and looking at human rights issues,
and also solutions that had,
it had a solution to some of the problems,
you know, much more than,
it had, it had programs
that really address the issues that really affected,
which was housing,
in the urban cities' houses,
this big problem,
urban cities, you see what I realized,
they're growing up in Mississippi,
those segregated as we were,
and as hard as times,
the difficulties to,
as life might have been here,
what I did not know was,
what it was like to go hungry, you know,
so, so, so I learned that children go hungry,
that children get binbarats,
that children actually get roaches in their ears,
and that these kind of things actually happen
in this urban environment that I had to find myself in, you know,
that these are real issues that really happen,
and that we had real programs
to address those issues, you know,
and ways of insisting that,
one of the things that I think,
that I can appreciate about the Black Pynthesis,
that the, the, the,
the pro-wantable things now that happens,
that free breakfast in schools,
were one of the programs that we initiated,
you know, we were the first to initiate
such a program, and, and the children had,
because the whole concept is that children could not learn,
adequately, if they're going to school hungry,
which they were, we actually went around up children,
who actually did not have breakfasts in the morning,
we'd round them up and take them, you know,
to the breakfast programs,
and, but I actually, when you're going back to what it looks like to be a female,
I actually used to do the women in the Black Pentecost,
one of the big things that I do talk about a lot,
and that that many of us,
particularly once we began to have families,
and so, so we did suffer a lot in terms of having to raise now
these children on our own,
and also having to be, you know,
that oftentimes we were put in positions,
like my going on the land was a very dangerous thing,
and unsafe thing to do with the woman, you know,
that it was a mother, who said mother,
but it was kind of expected of us to be
a guerrilla woman and mother too,
you got the same time, because I mean,
we looked at models, you know,
the, the Battle of Algiers, you know,
and, well, well, well, women actually
have babies on their back in the gun,
so that became a romantic kind of notion to that,
that we could actually do this to be, you know,
a revolutionary guerrilla and mother at the same time,
you know, so those were very challenging times,
and I remember, because I did try to,
once I began to have family,
I, I, I, I, one of my children to come first,
and I remember later, he is later a,
a, a, a man, a brother in the,
in the black Panther Party,
he said to me,
lead on.
That he always started with one of those bougie-type sisters,
and I said, well, why would she take it with bougie?
He said, because she just always seemed to be a BB,
BB, BB, BB about your children,
and stuff, so, you know,
it was those kinds of contradictions, you know,
that, that, that, that, that question, you know,
it was like, okay, you're so,
it's not okay to be a mother,
it's not okay to, to say, well, I just want to,
to, to, to spend my time making sure that these children
are safe, and, you know,
so, now, when you were asking, what was this question,
you just asked me?
What was like to be underground?
I tell you,
I actually never thought I would,
I think the reality of being underground,
and the reality of, actually, I've seen,
in my life, that there's two things that I have served my team,
and that is the experience that took me underground,
and that it, probably was one of the greatest mystics
that I've made in terms of my movement,
activity, in terms of being a pantheon.
It was, was, to turn in point in my life,
in a sense that, that I made this decision to do something,
to go against my better consciousness,
that, that, that, you shouldn't do this here,
you should let someone else do this here,
this is not for you to do, you have children,
but I think being a female again,
but back to female, it, I think,
it got down to a point,
particularly after the split in a black train to Florida,
where it was most challenging for women,
because it was like being in this place,
in this place, once in a split,
you didn't have, I didn't have the comfort again,
and it was like going from New York,
from Mississippi to New York,
I didn't no longer have, had to break between my life
as a civil rights activist,
and what do I do with my life here in New York,
and having (the) Black,
a panther party, now, of, very short limbs,
we were talking about a very short-lived experience,
because (the) Black played a part of his 68,
so in, in 1971, there was no longer an organized organization,
so again, it is what do I do with my life now,
movement has been moving my life now,
and so we were just pulled,
and just pulled in all kinds of directions,
and, and I did come home to Mississippi in 1971
to try to regroup,
but the, uh, uh, uh,
powers that be, was not going to have that,
because, um, I was, uh, once I came home,
I brought,
danger home to my family,
as my mother was put,
you know, that's,
so my family felt about me,
that I had brought danger,
I didn't invite danger,
danger followed me here,
because, uh, a female again,
it's like,
if you're female, then you know
what the system is,
and so, you know what's going on with these men folks,
and so, so, so danger followed me here to Mississippi,
and, um, so I stayed in Mississippi,
uh, uh, got uncomfortable,
and I, I felt,
no, I don't want to expose my family to this,
I don't want to expose all of the people,
you know, that I've gone to school with,
and I exposed to,
to the kind of COINTELPRO terrorism
that was going on during that period,
and there wasn't so much anything that I had done,
it was supposedly who I knew,
and so that kind of fresh,
I found myself back in New York,
and, um,
what followed that is still,
I'm just still feeling kind of displaced,
it's like,
movement is the life that I've known,
and so, what do I do,
and so, I did find myself
gravitating to more the radical wing of the,
of the split in the party,
and so, so, an incident in 1971,
uh, uh, set me on the run.
In the floor?
Yes, it did set me on the run,
but it was an incident in which I,
and my better judgment say,
don't do that,
because that's not the,
you have the children in there,
but, however,
it did set me on the run,
and so, so I stayed,
uh, I had my baby on the ground,
my baby daughter,
it was born on the ground,
and, um, so,
there was a, a, um,
I think, having a,
having a child on the ground,
I was, you know,
it was a, ye,
I had to go into,
to, to, to a,
a safe area,
with, with, with,
a group of,
my birth's what?
It was with white women,
whether I'm the ground of people,
and, um, so,
I stayed there until I had my,
until I had my baby.
And once I had my child, I had to make a decision of now.
So it was a turning point in my life.
So I did have to make a decision that,
because this is very, very dangerous now.
This is where life had really gotten dangerous
in the sense that, wow, this is life-threatening dangerous,
because now people that are at that out of us
are getting killed, they're going away,
and they're not coming back, they either going to jail,
they're getting killed.
And so what I eventually had to do was to just separate myself,
to protect myself, you know?
And so, so, so, that is pretty much it was rough.
To say the least, it was rough.
I managed to get my children back, back with me.
The two older ones were family members,
so I managed to get them back,
because that was the most depressing thing
that I had this experience was to be separated
to have my children, you know, here and there,
and not with me.
And so, so I managed to get my children back together,
and I managed to survive underground by, by, you know,
networking and creating my own support system in the sense of,
and so, four years, I lived four years underground,
and my children, knowing that I could not,
my children would grow up not knowing their grandparents
and not being able to have a normal life
like other children.
All of that went into play in terms of,
of me making a decision,
or how do I get myself out of this situation
that I found myself in, and how bad it actually to really look at
how bad this situation is, and what are my options.
And so, I did after four years of that life,
I began to explore my options,
of, of, of, of, clearing myself
of the situation that landed me there.
And so, I did get a lawyer to look into it,
and so I was able to, to get myself clear out of the situation
with pretty much a little slap on the hand,
pretty much, and because it was not as bad of a situation
as the South of Chicago situation,
not of that, not of that stuff having,
but it was a turbulent time for life,
because then I had to always be looking at all my shoulders.
I never knew, you know, when the day that I might be gone down,
I never knew that the day might come,
that I might get arrested and told for my children,
and that is the kind of life that I had to leave, you know.
I remember one day going to supermarket,
and I saw some police officers in it,
and I was like, oh, and they were looking at me,
and then I was like, this is the day.
And so, so it was that kind of life
of always feeling that this is the day.
And so, that was four years of that,
and then once I got myself cleared up,
my husband ended up in the biggest mess,
and so I ended up doing, instead of two years' probation,
then I ended up in the whole five years
because of that man they call my husband,
that's what I was told, you know, so it was, yeah.
So, I think you had something else.
But, I don't think that's the answer,
are there any final thoughts you have,
or things that you would want young people,
or others to know about your work,
civil rights, human rights, in the specificity
with the panthers?
Well, I think I would, young people,
I often try to tell them that stand up for something,
okay, that, that, if you don't stand for something,
you know, that, you know, that's why I do try to,
to encourage young people, but I also want them to,
to think, okay, because much of my environment,
particularly with the panthers,
and stuff, had much to do with, I mean,
when we were an organized organization,
I felt that there was something that gave me me,
and some fulfillment in my life,
and that I was doing things that kind of,
concretely, could make a difference,
and that, yes, that, that, that,
if we are going to, to be here, you know,
since we are here on this earth,
and this journey, that we should,
find something to make a difference, you know,
that it just, just be, you know,
and to know what it is, you know,
that you can do, what it is that you,
yourself, can do to make a difference,
and not the blindly following, you know,
so, so I think, you know, that,
that's one of the things that is encouraged,
not the blindly following, and,
that, that, a lot of young people,
particularly when it comes to the panthers,
a lot of young people want to know about the panthers,
but, but, there's the romanticism,
so, so, basically, I want to know the good,
the bad, and the ugly, you know,
that, that, I advise young people,
when studying the movement, to, to,
what I found is that, that, that, now,
even with doing this interview here,
I'm wondering how much,
do we, what do we, we tell people that,
that, that, that, that, young people tend to think that,
that, that, we were just kind of born,
that, that, that we did super things,
that, that, that, that's beyond, you know,
that, that, I didn't know anything about politics
when I, when I, but, the,
the open, so, the open,
to, to new ideas, but, to also,
find what really works for you, you know?
Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
Very much, and I appreciate you doing the interview.
Wow.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress,
and the Smithsonian National Museum of African-American
History and Culture.